news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
sometimes in the political analysis
space we over analyze
obvious things and then other times
we're under exposing major stories
and then sometimes it's sort of both at
once and that's the case here
top trump advisor went on tv yesterday
and three times refused to deny that the
trump administration was or would
uh accept was accepting or would accept
foreign campaign
assistance and opposition research on
joe biden and then ultimately ended up
sort of saying well we're not accepting
it right now
uh without actually saying we would not
accept it this is both
a major story that should be 110 exposed
but it's also a completely obvious
position of the campaign
that requires no analysis because it is
exactly what donald trump has been
saying for months or years that he would
do so let's take a look
here is jason miller uh trump campaign
advisor
we've seen clips of him before wacky guy
interviewed by chris wallace on fox news
sunday yesterday and this is the first
attempt from chris wallace asking has
the trump campaign
received information from foreign groups
or nationals on joe biden
or joe biden's family will you
accept it if it were to be offered this
is the first shot
at getting an answer to the question can
you state flatly that neither the trump
administration nor the trump campaign
has received any information from
foreign groups foreign nationals about
either joe biden or his family
and can you state flatly that neither
the administration nor the
campaign will accept foreign assistance
chris that's a silly question i mean the
folks who have actually taken foreign
assistance for the clinton campaign
four years ago i mean that entire shady
dossier they put together was from a
british spy
uh no we're going to go and beat joe
biden fair and square here absolutely
but i think you should have asked the
same question to do with his prospective
running mates and senator duckworth and
karen bass because just as we saw
four years ago it was the democrats who
took foreign assistance
so look at the specifics of what jason
miller says it's a silly question well
that's not a denial
it was democrats who did that that's not
a denial
we're going to beat joe biden fair and
square trump has already said he
considers
uh at least checking out foreign
opposition research as
being okay so therefore in their mind
it's arguably fair and square to do
exactly what chris wallace is asking
about
so chris wallace tries again here's a
second time can you flatly state
that the trump campaign and the
administration will not accept foreign
assistance this time
chris i said that's an absolutely silly
question uh we're going to go and win
this race fair
again not a denial this isn't that tough
right jason miller says
for a second time that's a silly
question
we're going to win fair and square trump
believes
it is fair to win with foreign
opposition research so chris wallace
is right to be skeptical of the way that
jason miller
is answering these questions let's now
back up a few seconds
and then we're going to hear the third
attempt and the third
sort of non-answer uh we're going to go
and win this race fair
i'm just asking for it i'm asking for an
answer it's a it's a yes or no question
jason
chris there is no foreign assistance
that's happening in this campaign but i
would ask you
to make sure that the democrats aren't
going to do what they tried to pull four
years ago
because that's exactly they're going to
try to find every possible way
to cheat and steal this election 100
percent there
is no foreign assistance that's
happening now again that's not
a denial that they would accept it and
of course
this is laying the groundwork for if
later
it's discovered that the trump campaign
did accept
foreign opposition research or info they
can hide behind look
miller said that at the time they hadn't
received any
and maybe at the time that was true
and they could argue a technicality but
this this really is a big deal
but it's also not shocking in that
donald trump admits this donald trump in
that
infamous interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos about a year ago i think
it was
might have been um was it may of 2019 i
don't even remember when it was but
roughly in the last year or 15 months
donald trump said to george
stephanopoulos yeah
i would look at stuff from russia i
would look at stuff from china sure why
not
so jason miller can't really say no
because trump has already said yes
publicly that's the crazy part of it his
answer to
can you categorically and definitively
say
that you won't accept foreign help is
it's not happening right now
and it's a silly question not
particularly
convincing now also there's this focus
from them
on democrats doing it that's a new
talking point you heard it used there by
jason miller
asked about what the trump campaign did
is or will do
um saying well it's democrats who
actually did it you know christopher
steele the dossier
democrats don't need foreign assistance
for information on donald trump
democrats
don't even need really domestic
assistance because trump has done it all
anything and everything you can imagine
in the light of day
and that's why i i'm sort of both
optimistic
and preemptively depressed if we can't
beat
trump given what he's done in the last
three and a half years
in a sense the country deserves trump
for another four years i mean i
i don't i don't know how to say it if
trump cheats to win right if the will of
the people actually is for trump to be
defeated
and trump cheats to win that's different
but if in a fair and square election
this guy gets reelected
on balance tens of millions of us of
course don't agree with it
but on balance don't we deserve another
four years if after all this we don't
remove the guy
something i've been thinking about